I turn right now to one of the best ever
to do what he does and which is beat the
crap out of people in an octagon am i
lying you tell me you're not lying he's
one of the best ever UFC 239 John Jones
is taking on Thiago Santos who again
according to the UFC a press release is
provided to me by Rich Eisen show
researcher el Zorro he's a Brazilian
knockout artist which again I would love
to just be 10 seconds in my life on the
planet I'd even be I'd even I'd even say
just for 10 seconds to be called that
and then submitted I would do it just
intro to me an immediate submission yeah
certainly from the Octagon with Jon
bones Jones joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you John man I'm a
black guy and I know you can't see me
but I'm over here blushing right now
John John just look oh yeah look at your
resume and I'm blushing now yeah you
know I again this the first time you've
ever chatted so unless we've met before
and I don't remember meeting you know
the UFC light heavyweight champion but
you you don't strike me as a modest
individual every now and then John right
you know my job is to be an entertainer
man people want to hear you talk crap
people want to want to hear a champion
undefeated champion sound confident you
know and so big part of my job but I
mean he's got to know me man I'm like
I'm a teddy bear man I'm always was not
close friends my daughter's my mines my
dogs very simple man
okay so let's before we get to the
father dog lover part let's get to the
crap talker part and give them what they
want John Jones when you think when you
think of Thiago Santos what do you say
no to be dead honest I have nothing but
respect for the guy man it's hard to
talk crap about such a respectable man I
said well my head to Santos and I had to
stand for it means hammer in Portuguese
they call him the hammer
really respectable dude man he's a
single father who's taking care of his
kids he's from the worst area in Brazil
and he made it out of there
it became a now he has a foundation
right there in that area that's like a
Boys & Girls Club so you know he served
in the Brazilian military he's a
stand-up dude man he's a Christian Jews
and I got nothing but respect for him
but unfortunately he's my ax is my
opponent
you know he's won his last four fights
last three being by knockout you know
guys a black belt and and uh muy Thai
he's a black belt and and jujitsu and
he's a he's a game opponent I think a
lot of Brazilians are flying to Las
Vegas this Saturday and I to watch him
beat me and and man I'm so excited about
this challenge man this guy's one of the
scariest guys I've fought in a very long
time I think it's gonna be just a hell
of a fight the witness that satury
coming up Saturday July 16 mobile arena
UFC 239 what about Daniel Cormier what
do you what do you think of one his name
gets mentioned oh man Daniel Daniel
Cormier is our current heavyweight
champion of the world he moved up to the
heavyweight division because he lost to
me twice at the light heavyweight
division and I think he's a great
ambassador for mixed martial arts man
he's a stand-up guy he's always been
assumed he speaks very well I think a
lot of people look at cage fighters as
like these barbaric crazy tattooed up
you know I was just wild boys you know
and really there's a lot of men a lot of
gentlemen a lot of college-educated men
and and in the UFC and Daniel was one of
them I'm grateful that he's our
Heavyweight Champion and any of these
everyone to rematch against me he can
come back down to the light heavyweight
division and lose again so you won't go
you won't go up to him you won't go up
to the heavy way you think about doing
that no I won't I won't so so I was the
youngest was the youngest champion in
UFC history and I said I still hold that
record at age 23 I won my first title
and I've won about 14 world titles since
then and I've had the opportunity to go
up to heavyweight and challenged many
heavyweight champions over the
years and I never took the opportunity
and now a lot of people really want to
see me bump up and challenge Daniel
Cormier a guy that I've defeated twice I
don't really know why him out of all the
champions in a heavyweight that there's
been that everyone wants to see me fight
him a heavyweight i'ma beat the guy
twice you know first time by unanimous
decision and second time by knockout so
I felt I had nothing to prove and and
things aren't really things are really
good at laterally division they say if
it's not broke don't fix it well I mean
well I'll be able I have to wait for a
little while I hear you Jonna a lot of
John Jones you're in the Richards Joe
there are some who may say by the way
which is a way of somebody in my savvy
position of saying something that I'm
not going to take ownership of but just
say other people are saying that that
you've you've run out of people to fight
in the light heavyweight champ division
like what else is there for you to do in
that weight class John Mann I think I
think you know I've been hearing that a
lot lately and I think I think it's an
insult to all the guys that are still as
a light heavyweight division there's a
lot of young men that are coming up that
I haven't faced yet and they're young
they're hungry they're ambitious they
have a dream of having their life
changed by winning a world title and and
I'm I'm I'm the goal for a lot of these
guys have a big target on my back and to
just leave the division when I'm small
enough to make the division I think I
think it's doing all of the young
dreamers and injustice I think I need to
give them their chance to at least
compete against me and quite frankly get
their ass kicked
what about the idea of maybe going into
the square in the same way that Conor
McGregor did it John obviously didn't
work out for him
and no dog food yeah we ever think about
doing somewhat agree yeah man you know
I'm I'm a realist and I'm a real guy for
the most part man and you know I've
spent my years a grip wrestling and and
it helped me transition it to be a
really good mixed martial arts fighters
fighter only because I can I can slam a
guy to the ground he's hitting me too
hard with his fists and then the box
attendant ring you got to stand there
and take those punches and if you get
knocked down you got to get that ten
colonists and back up you know and I
just I don't know a minute I don't think
it's for me man I'd rather be able to
use all my challenge and kick a guy and
wrestle guy and choking guy than just to
sit there and take a whole bunch of
punches to the face I just really
appreciate you know being a mixed
martial arts fighter and dude I don't
want to get punched by Deontay Wilder
Louie's many boy they hit really hard
I'm just gonna stay in my lane and keep
choking people out you know John that is
a that is a wise maneuver we also had
Tyson Fury in the seat right next to me
about a month ago and every time he
stood up he kept going kept going it
didn't stop every time he stood up it I
mean that is these are some serious
people there's no doubt about that
oh yeah yeah man yeah I want no parts of
high security none of these guys they're
not I humble enough to know what my lane
is and that's in the UFC well all that
said John Jones you turned 32 in a
couple weeks how much longer do you plan
to do this
yes I'll turn 3200 wine 19th which is
really exciting
I feel really young you know a lot of
the guys that are ranked top 10 in the
world they're on their upper 30s and I'm
still a little early so and I've been
I've been blessed to have never been
knocked out in practice or in there in
the Octagon so I feel like I have a
strong healthy brain and my body's
healthy and and I don't see why well
stop anytime soon I'm trying to get to a
point in my career where everyone's
lives around me is getting affected
financially and things like that and and
I love it man and I just want to I want
to ride the wheels and - so the lows
fall off man and just change as many
lives as I can so your older brother
Arthur played for the Colts Ravens
Redskins your younger brother is one of
the best - his position in the
profession right now for the Cardinals
formerly of of the Patriots in Chandler
John Jones why did you never go forward
in football like these guys did your
brothers well I did I tried to play
football walk me through that yeah I did
I did I I just I was never as good as
they were I went to Kevin football I was
always like third string you know I was
like six foot four 170 and they had me
on the defensive line and you know
opposed to my brother it was six foot
four to 75 to 80 and you know I was just
trying to keep up with those guys and
and I wasn't answering and my brothers
were team captains and they were always
first string from the very beginning and
I my restaurant close he pulled me to
the side you know he knew I was kind of
a lost kid in high school and he said
John if you if you listen to me and if
you take this wrestling thing seriously
you know you do summer camp and you do
the things I tell you to do I promise
you man I'll get you into college and
you know help you find your niche and I
did I focused my energy into the sport
of wrestling and it led me to a
scholarship to wrestle in Iowa and when
I was done with school and Iowa
I found a jujitsu school which was a lot
like wrestling and I got really good at
that pretty fast and that guy encouraged
me to try to become a full-fledged mixed
martial arts fighter and nine months
after my very first practice I had
signed a contract with the toughest
organization be a part of would be in
the UFC and shortly after that became
the youngest champion in sports history
and and I realized that I found my
calling in life
hmm and what position were you trying to
play in football same or on defense I
was out of the defensive end but I was
freaking terrible absolutely terrible
well in a better waterboy for sure well
I mean some of your best moves would
definitely earn you a 15-yard
unsportsmanlike conduct penalty I would
think if you tried any of your UFC
optimum and Hoover's on a football radar
and that would be it that's 15 yards
each time I imagine oh yeah sure dude
I'm always trying to you know having to
Super Bowl champion brothers and I'm
always trying to challenge myself
against them when we're at barbecues or
whenever we get the chance to be
together and they're like nah man don't
be kicking at me
don't be punching at me at that game
they don't want anything to do with it
with the kicking and punching game well
John if you're when you're in Los
Angeles next come on in I'd love to have
you here in studio your love - that
would be great I really would we do a
lot of uh media tours in LA and have you
talked to one of the PR members I'm sure
they consider that I'd be honored to
comments video are you you're tight with
glades right with Jay Glazer are you
tight with Jay man okay maybe I'll see
you on break above Jim because you know
I work out there too John that's where
that's where on the the Jewish knockout
artist come on John come on somebody's
gotta really call that I will all right
John I'll see you tomorrow
good luck this weekend myself a
shameless Instagram blog please John
yeah good Johnnie bones
yes sir at Johnny bones and the really
cool thing is I have a have a really
good video aquifer and photographer here
with me and these guys have been
collecting all types of bold
behind-the-scenes footage of myself and
Holly Holm who's going to be the co-main
event if you guys are interested lean
into Saturday and I was some sort of
behind the scenes footage stuff and my
photos please follow me on Instagram and
Johnny Bono and ybo any yet there you go
and we we already instagrams stuff out
for this too so you know give us a give
us a little regram or whatever you want
to do and we're all we're all off and
run here we've had Holly here I mean
again you've got to come here John it's
that simple she is yeah make sure you
guys tag me on Instagram and I'll attack
you back and let's promote each other
and there you go all right John thanks
for the call well chat soon yeah you got
that's John Jones for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app